Hi, I'm the great-grandson and the tip of today.
of the next level chips is about printing at
from your android app you
knew that it is possible from a
android application submit a document
to be printed on some printer
remote
this is exactly how cloud print is
possible you print on any
printer that is shared
remotely and even more points
shared of a friend of yours who
offer access you can send to
even print your home your work
beauty and see how to set up here
this link is on our screen oriented
how to do this sharing
including some companies already
come factory ready for you only
plug in internet and use google
cloud print a girlfriend here
diagram that shows how you have done this
service is seeing here that has
book notebook tablet cell phone through
of the cloud hits the google servers
which will show what the impressions are
available in your account reminding you
be your own printer or
shared with you can integrate this
in your android application is very simple
The first step is for you to go
address that is on the copy two screen
codes that are there are two files
one is out and the other is marty mcfly where
will be the code that will select the
printer you can use
after that you will use case
still not use the internet in your
application this permission so that the
application accesses the internet
if you already use it because it is consuming
watch out if there's no problem
and finally you will add the action of
call this print screen
you can have a button for example
print and not a click list of that button
you will put this code that nothing
more is than shooting the entente
I had that one that you configured from
code you got from google site
if I have one more information in one
detail also visits if this interest
that is there in the video and you will see more
especially the club, even if you
want to use 100 hundred apps
android
this is the tip of today and until the next